we're talking about something called
time which is equal to two pi so there's
been a huge amount in a bit discussion
about this right across the internet
there's even a Tau manifesto so one of
the real advocates of Thai versus pi is
very hard and I thoroughly recommend you
go and visit her video Brady may put the
link in somewhere maybe down here or up
there or over there somewhere
for some people it's not an issue and
initially my response was why are people
arguing about this this is talk nonsense
because if you want to use tow then you
just go tau I'll repeat it tau is equal
to to pay and then proceed it's more
than that though because with mats and
with physics what you want to strive for
all the time is clarity particular when
you're teaching this stuff it's far too
easy if you've been teaching this for
fifteen years like I have not to be able
to put yourself in the mindset who's
doing this right from the start and so
if you've got schoolchildren who are
coming to trigonometry you're coming to
angles who are coming to PI and circles
and circumference and radius for the
first time you do not want to confuse
them you want to minimize the confusion
and moreover in math Sun in physics a
really important property is symmetry
and you want to try and have the most
elegant concise description of something
here's my very wonky circle and let's
put our center there and that's a radius
R and from there to there you all know I
hope let's do it in a different color is
D and we define pi very simply as the
ratio of the circumference to the
diameter and this holds true for any
circle regardless of its size
pi crops up in very many different ways
and the first thing we've got to think
about is how we define angle so let's
draw another circle on this very crumply
brown paper if we start here at this
point and we move around and come back
to the same point that's how many
degrees we ready 360 2060 degrees so
there's a much more natural way of
defining an angle let's take a circle
again here's our radius we're going to
call that our again and let's say that
instead of walking all the way around we
instead walk
a distance-r along here so that's our as
well and that angle and we call angles
conventionally in physics you can call
it whatever you like but conventionally
we call it we do not denote it by
theater that angle when this arc length
is equal to the radius is equal to one
Radian okay so that's that's a much more
natural definition because here we're
basing it on just on the fundamental
properties of the circle instead of
going well that's 360 degrees we're
saying that when we go around a certain
arc length which is equal to the radius
that's a Radian now the question is how
many radians do we get if we go all the
way around the circle how many radians
does that turn out to be well it turns
out to be two pi radians and the reason
is because you remember that the
circumference length is two PI R right
so two pi radians here's where the
debate kicks in because some
particularly Bob Polly if I hope I
pronounced that right it all stems from
this wonderful paper pi is Ron Bob Polly
but he argued well it's in this rather
confusing so you go round one turn and
instead of being PI radians it's two pi
radians I have a daughter who's 9
another daughter who's six my daughter
who's 9 is starting to look at shapes
and starting to look at angles doing
basic geometry and I can see how this is
going to be a big problem I'm looking
around for the pier for that and what
we're going to do now is we're going to
look at a number of different angles so
we define angles counterclockwise so we
go that way rather than that way quite
why we do that I have no idea
it's convention here's where it gets
interesting zero radians exactly the
same we go around a quarter of the
circle that angle is not PI over 4 it's
PI over 2 that's already confusing we go
around the circle a bit more instead of
being PI over 2 because we've gone half
way around it's pi
and here it's 1 and 1/2 PI 3 PI over 2
and here it's to pay it natural unit is
1 turn natural unit is you go around
once and yet when you go around once
that's 2 pi no I think that's confusing
not your
at a basic elementary level but that
that use of to pay instead of payer
instead of something which represents
one turn which represents one revolution
well let's just redefine that let's say
that tau is equal to two pi one turn is
equal to two pi
and let's put the term just put the
painting to one side so that's one turn
so we start off with zero how far have
we gone we'll look on a quarterly round
we've done a Rev we've done a quarter of
a revolution that's tau over four much
more natural this is ty over two because
we've got a half way around its natural
what's this one Brady that's going to be
three quarters okay exactly and this
one's going to be tau and into 2 & 3 2 &
4 2 & 5 2 and that's much more natural
and of course any professional physicist
or mathematician or scientist is gonna
go well you know what it's
straightforward I just write if I want
to use that I just write that I continue
may my equation my analysis I continue
my derivation using using tau but that's
not the point it's not about the
professional physicist it's about
teaching this stuff a toupee appears
throughout physics all the way from the
very large scale all the way right down
to quantum mechanics and I'll get on to
quantum mechanics analysis let me show
you a simple demo first of all mass on a
spring we let that bob up and down it
performs something which is the bin of
so many first-year undergraduates lives
and physics which is called simple
harmonic motion goes up and down what
describes that or we call it circular
motion and what describes that is a sine
wave and the period of that motion again
is two pi terms of how atoms vibrate
atoms vibrate all the time in molecules
we describe that in terms of an angular
frequency which describe it in terms of
a frequency but often we use something
called Omega which is an angular
frequency which is 2 pi times F and this
is where it gets really really
interesting because we even as
physicists we even extract out that that
factor of 2 pi because we have something
called Planck's constant it's a
fundamental constant that crops up
throughout quantum
and we actually redefine it we have got
something called hairspray and here
tomorrow is equal to hitch over 2 pi and
one of the reasons this toupee factor
crops off time and time again throughout
physics is that when we get down to the
quantum level matter behaves like a wave
it's got a Silla tarry motion associated
with it it moves back and forth with a
period we can describe that in terms of
waves which have a period of 2pi it
crops up absolutely everywhere here's my
favorite equation that is called Fourier
transform and as you'll see you've got
two pi here but not only do you have to
pay there that's a normal guy just two
pi F you've got a 2pi factor and as
another alma go up here what that does
that's got to pace absolutely everywhere
now what we could do and you can just
replace this instead of having 1 over
root 2 pi have 1 over tau here have 1
over root tag that's not the point I
really don't think that's the point if
you go to the various websites where are
they that the Tau manifesto and the
payment of festal and they have this
game with a bat each other back and
forth well look at this equations more
simple if you put tau and this recursion
small simple you put PI and that's not
the point it's about the fundamental
teaching of this for professional
physicist it were not going to change
this I really do not think we're going
to change this if you open up any
textbook that has a 2 pi 2 pi there
actually there's one earlier on so open
a book up at random you're very very
likely in a first-year physics textbook
in any physics textbook to come across a
2 pi we are not going to change these
textbooks that's not the point the point
is when you're teaching this stuff Tao
is a better representation is a better
concept the idea that you do one turn
and that's Tao as opposed to two pi
radians it's just a much better way of
explaining this no one's going to change
why are we even talking about it are we
just saying this is what we should have
done yes it is what it is what we've
sort of done Euler I think possibly had
an opportunity to change this hundreds
of years ago we should have done it we
haven't done it
perhaps we could go you know from this
point onwards think about writing
textbooks and at least mention Tao I
think what we need to do is you can
perhaps in a textbook like this it's
true out it's going to talk about to pay
but we could see a right at the start
though there is this concept of Tao many
students find it very helpful and
introduce it and perhaps then there'll
be a gradual evolution towards Tao I
doubt it I really doubt it but it might
be nice to think so you've got it
keeping your mind when you when you're
doing calculations and actually if
you're if you are season after teasing
sampling and the effects and frequency
shifting to get it into the right pitch
but I really just I'll play of a local
again because they are really quite neat
if I can find the channel and also yeah
what harms here because the half tells
you this works out just as nicely
because if you were